the core curriculum of hillsdale college  is the profound thing  that means it's at the foundation  everything built on that  it's an assembly of things the knowledge  of which is really essential to realize  our full humanity you know a lot of  students come in and they say well why  do i have to take a science course you  know this is not part of the liberal  arts having a good understanding of the  sciences helps you better integrate your  other understandings within the other  fields mathematics and philosophy have a  lot to say to one another  history and the sciences have a lot to  say to one another  you gotta have a foundation of multiple  things to really appreciate the specific  things that you then study in earnest  it's about  realizing our full intellectual moral  spiritual and social political humanity  we're dedicated to studying  the highest things  that human beings can know